So you had to put me somewhere. Yeah. So I'm mainly a health services researcher and leukemia
doc, but my other hat is a bioethicist. So like every good conference, we need a little AI
fear-mongering. I didn't come up with this title and I don't want to boil the ocean of the whole
healthcare industry in seven minutes. And so I'm going to narrow it to kind of AI's involvement
in clinical hematology oncology research. So there's currently kind of this large gap between
where AI is being used in healthcare and where we want to be with it. Currently it's sold to us as
something that can improve everything from picking the color of your lab coat to solving
your existential crises. So we really want to be in this place where it's consistently augmenting
trial design, performance, how we apply those data to patients. And these kind of big questions we
should be asking are really what the problem that's being brought in to solve and kind of,
is it worth it from the cost risk benefit perspective? Now, as it relates to AI and
clinical oncology and drug development, we have clinical decision support, trial design,
and review. And so we're going to be looking at how we can improve everything from picking the
color of your lab coat to solving your existential crises. So we really want to be in this place where
we can improve everything from picking the color of your lab coat to solving your existential crises. So we really want to be in this place where
the things that are at the forefront for AI in this area. And while clinical decision support
tools are really likely to follow that strictly regulated FDA pathway for clearance or approval,
this is still a relatively small footprint. On the right, you can see there to date are kind of less
than 20 AI approved devices in hematology. And these are mainly for clinical applications like
looking at cells under microscopes. Trial design, recruitment, drug discovery, however, are going to
forever remain outside of that regulatory scope, which means they're really in somewhat of a wild
west, virtually no specific guidance or standards apart from when they touch things like HIPAA. And
this, of course, raises some foundational ethical concerns for development and application.
For those of you who have read any T.E. Lawrence or, you know, Peter O'Toole, Lords of Arabia,
these are my five pillars of wisdom for assessing those issues in AI as it applies to clinical
hematology research. We have bias and representation, transparency and
explainability, responsibility, accountability, privacy, data governance, and then kind of this
impact and research and potentially clinical skills. But I probably won't get to that last one.
So for bias, we all have myriad biases for how we interpret evidence to how we think of other people.
There's been a lot of concern, rightfully, about how AI can be biased upon the data,
data we put into it and beyond. And these are, you know, critical problems, but they're largely
going to occur in the background of clinical care research related tools, and of course, need to be
considered when AI is being developed or emergent biases like I'm listing here after it's developed
and applied in a new situation. But the more important aspect in my mind of assessing bias
is really how do our human biases for you, your team interact with those of the AI. A recent study
evaluating diagnostic reasoning found that an LLM alone outperformed a physician as well as that
same physician with the same LLM that was working on it alone. And the reason I note that is that the
LLM alone did better because when the physician was interacting with it, the physician's anchoring
bias actually led to worse diagnostic reasoning. And so this speaks to the fact that we really need
to train ourselves for how we're using these tools and use them to check our biases as well as those
of the LLMs. Now, one of the main issues for AI models is if in the extent to which we know what
the heck they're doing inside, we have a variety of ways in which AI can be incorporated into
our work. So if we know what the heck they're doing inside, we have a variety of ways in which
AI can be incorporated into our work. So if we know what the heck they're doing inside, we have a variety
of ways in which AI can be incorporated into our work. So if we know what the heck they're doing
inside, we have a variety of ways in which AI can be incorporated into our work. So if we know what
the heck they're doing inside, we have a variety of ways in which AI can be incorporated into our work.
The questions here are kind of what needs explicit consent, but really more critically,
if we can't explain how the AI is making decisions, can we actually consent patients to the risks and
harms that involves something for decision-making at all? And this issue of inexplicability also
extends the thing outside of the clinical realm, like a consent document for a patient. Like if we
ask an LLM a question, we really need to be prepared to kind of interrogate its responses
to the point that we're convinced that it's neither hallucinating nor engaging in logical fallacies.
And now for responsibility and accountability, kind of we're used to being these
arbiters, gatekeepers of expertise and being accountable to patients,
but now we have AI models that are offering this independent expertise.
And this conceptual diagram offers what I hope we'll move towards, which is really where we have
clinicians and AI models kind of augmenting each other's expertise and limiting each other's errors
and while we continue to provide that essential kind of human component of medicine and also
maintain both legal accountability and authority. The concern, however, shown in the right stat
headline is that clinicians might be cut out. And this leaves this gaping question of who's
accountable when that happens. And this can equally easily be applied to issues in trials,
such as if we have AIs kind of doing automated Tuva response
assessment or AI arbitration or in trial design where there's a lot of context that we can take
into account that's not really available in data form to AI. For things like privacy, this has been
an issue since personal data became recognized as a property right in the 1960s. And the kind of these
twin privacy concerns that AI raises are kind of increasing diffusion of data into models to the
point that we really don't know whose data are where and when they're accessible. And then we also have this
thing called adversarial AI models, meaning like people are using it for bad purposes that can
really substantially lower the bar for re-identification of patients from seemingly
unidentifiable data. A nice example from this came out in August and this is just the one of
the figures from that paper on the right, which is essentially where they took one of those seemingly
unidentifiable pieces of medical data in EKG, which had been deposited in "de-identified" public
data sets and actually re-identified 85% of those pieces of data. And this is something that we've
been looking at for a long time. And we're really excited to see what that looks like in the future.
So we're really excited to see what that looks like in the future. And we're excited to see what it looks
like in the future. And we're excited to see what it looks like in the future. For our clinical trials,
this is most relevant for the myriad genomic data that we're producing and the extent to which we
can really confidently tell patients that their data will be protected and remain private. Right
now, data governance models are really in kind of the infant stage of development, both for academic
institutions and still for many companies. And I'm happy to talk about that more with people if you're
interested. But really, where's this going? Where's the impact? Like all tools, its impact
can be revelatory or damning. It all really depends on how it's being used. The fake forest
plot that I made up here isn't to say that these are the directions in which these concepts will
take us better or worse, but just to say that each has the potential to do either. AI models could
really help us develop less biased eligibility criteria, which have unnecessarily excluded patients
for many years. But it can just as easily lead to kind of algorithmic exclusion of patients if not
done well. And we're excited to see what that looks like in the future. And I'm happy to talk about
that. And I'm happy to talk about that in the future. And I'm happy to talk about that in the future.
And similar opportunities exist for synthetic control arms and automated endpoint detection.
So reaching to the end of my seven minutes, how do I solve this for you in one slide? I can't,
but at least I can give some digestible outline of framework for approaching these pillars. These
include thinking about diversity and equity from the off, which is thankfully terms I can use
because we're in Canada. Maintaining our reasoning and humanity in the loop, while at the same time
kind of recognizing the bias. And that's what we're trying to do. And that's what we're trying to do.
And that's what we're trying to do. And that's what we're trying to do. And the biases that we
bring to the table and that AI models can help abrogate, sharing what we learned about the use
of these models in these contexts, continuing this open dialogue with regulators. And finally,
making sure that monitoring persists kind of throughout this AI life cycle. Thank you.